GOVERNOR, ALWAYS GREAT TO HAVE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND EXPERIENCE
ON THE SHOW.
I WILL LEAN HEAVILY ON YOU.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
CALCULATIONS NOW THAT NEED TO BE
MADE?
I KNOW THAT EACH STATE IS
DIFFERENT, AS I WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM, IS THERE AN OVERARCHING
THING THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD
LOOKLOOK AT?
>> I THINK WE SAID IS THE KEY.
SEATS AT THE SAME.
SOME ARE DENSELY POPULATED.
NEW YORK, NEW JERSEY.
THOSE STATES ARE NEEDING TO BE
CLOSED LONGER.
IF YOU ARE IN WYOMING, IF YOU
ARE IN MONTANA, IF YOU ARE IN
OTHER PARTS OF RURAL AMERICA,
THERE MAY NOT BE A REASON FOR
YOU TO BE OLD UP AT HOME LIKE A
HERMIT RIGHT NOW.
THAT DECISION IS BEST MADE
CLOSER TO THE PEOPLE BEING
AFFECTED BY IT.
THAT’S WHY I THINK THE PRESIDENT
WOULD BE VERY WISE TO MAKE THIS
DECISION, LEAVE THIS IN THE
HANDS OF THE GOVERNORS AND THE
MAYORS AND THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO
THEIR POPULATIONS.
SOME HAVE OVERREACTED, HARRIS.
SOME HAVE BEEN HEAVY-HANDED.
SOME OF IT IS ILLOGICAL AND
IRRATIONAL, AND I THINK THEY
WILL PAY THE PRICE FOR HAVING
USURPED PEOPLE’S BASIC
LIBERTIES.
YOU KNOW, WE CAN TALK ABOUT
THAT, BUT THIS IS A RAMPING UP
OF THE ECONOMY AGAIN.
IT WON’T HAPPEN WITH A FLIP OF
THE SWITCH.
IT’LL HAPPEN WITH SORT OF AN
ENTRANCE RAMP, IF YOU WILL, TO
THE FREEWAY.
>> Harris: I HAVE A FOLLOW-UP
TO THAT.
I’M GOING TO POINT OUT
SOUTH DAKOTA, AND THE GOVERNOR
THERE.
YOU SAY SOME HAVE BEEN
OVERREACTING, OR HEAVY-HANDED.
CERTAINLY THAT’S THE CASE.
YOU SEE PEOPLE PROTESTING NOW.
LOOK AT MICHIGAN, WHERE THEY
FEEL LIKE SOME OF THE RULES ARE
JUST ARBITRARY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE POPPING OF
THE CASE NUMBER IS NOW, AND THE
PROBLEMS THEY ARE HAVING WITH
COVID-19 IN A PLACE LIKE
SOUTH DAKOTA, THAT HADN’T BEEN A
HOT SPOT, THAT HADN’T SEEN THOSE
THINGS, AND THE GOVERNOR HAD
TAKEN A DIFFERENT WAY.
THE MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS HAVE
SAID IT COULD HAPPEN ANY PLACE,
AND THAT IT LIKELY WILL.
WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THAT?
>> IT CERTAINLY CAN HAPPEN ANY
PLACE.
I THINK THAT’S WHERE THE BASIC
PROTOCOLS OF HAND WASHING,
SOCIAL DISTANCING, NOT DOING THE
TRADITIONAL HANDSHAKE, THERE ARE
SOME THINGS THAT STILL CAN BE
DONE.
BUT WE CANNOT WAIT UNTIL THE
VERY LAST CASE OF COVID-19 IS
ERADICATED BEFORE THERE IS SOME
LEVEL OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN
THIS COUNTRY.
THERE WILL BE A COUNTRY TO COME
BACK TO.
THAT IS THE CALCULATED RISK, AND
IT IS ONE THAT HAS TO BE TAKEN.
THAT SOUNDS RATHER AUDACIOUS,
BUT HARRIS, WE CANNOT HOLD UP
IN OUR HOMES FOR 18 MONTHS.
THE ECONOMY WON’T HANDLE IT.
I’M NOT KIDDING, THERE WILL BE
NOTHING TO COME BACK TO.
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS WILL NOT
HAVE A BUSINESS.
PEOPLE WHO WORK THERE WON’T HAVE
JOBS.
THE GOOD OLD GOVERNMENT CAN’T
JUST KEEP SHELLING OUT TRILLIONS
OF DOLLARS INDEFINITELY.
THERE’S GOT TO BE A POINT AT
WHICH WE GET BACK TO WORK, WE
TAKE PRECAUTIONS, AND IF THERE
DOES COME ANOTHER HOT SPOT OR,
LET’S SAY, A SIGNIFICANT
OUTBURST, THEN YOU DEAL WITH IT.
BUT YOU DEAL WITH IT AT THAT
PLACE AND AT THAT TIME.